after a bloody battle I put it into it
all in the catacombs beneath the city
the penguin two-face at lady Arkham were
the first real challenge I faced as the
Batman but they would not be the last
actions have consequences
and in season one of Telltale's Batman
series Bruce Wayne learned this truths
the hard way when his father Thomas
Wayne was revealed to be one of the most
powerful criminals in Gotham history
while the events of season 1 mostly
wrapped up neatly one very important
thread was left laying bare at one point
in order to escape incarceration at
Arkham Asylum Bruce Wayne briefly allied
himself with John Doe a green haired
pale faced lunatic with a chilling
air-to-air grin and as we all know
actions have consequences when I get out
of here you're gonna owe me a favor okay
just one but the enigma season 2 episode
1 of tale tells Batman series approaches
this loose end with a deft touch
allowing the threat of John Doe to
linger in the background ever present
but simmering instead it pivots to a
compelling take on the Riddler who is
excellently voiced by Robert Atkin
Downes
although Riddler is primarily used as
the setup for a much bigger threat
telltale still does justice to the
character with a gripping self-contained
story telltale has made a few changes to
Edward nygma to present him in a way
that while not completely unique puts a
different spin on him in this universe
Riddler existed before Bruce Wayne
became Batman but has been missing for
some time his return to Gotham is not
only an ominous sign of things to come
but the spark that ignites a number of
fights for Batman and Bruce Wayne to
fight in typical Riddler fashion he
immediately sets about challenging the
intellect of Gotham so-called Savior the
initial confrontation is a brutal Casino
brawl which culminates in the villain
leaving The Dark Knight with a mystery
to solve a small strange box that must
be figured out or people are gonna get
hurt the bulk of this episode is spent
unraveling the mysteries of the box and
then dealing with the fallout but the
search for answers has a devastating
impact on the people around Batman kalto
isn't wasting any time as episode 1 has
a few harrowing moments and tough
decisions by the time the episode has
wrapped up the Riddler has made a
permanent mark on the life of Bruce
Wayne and
Batman watch help commissioner for all
his preaching Batman knows when to
sacrifice a pawn to win the game the
means by which players drive the
narrative in season two hasn't changed
drastically from the previous season's
investigations still involve finding
Clues by moving around environments and
interacting with specific objects and
puzzle solving is similarly rudimentary
while the first game the investigation
sequences weren't much more complicated
they at least had a multitude of
variables to think about in this episode
however the solutions were obvious and
the steps to solving conundrums were
simple and it much feel like the world's
greatest detective that's a match
episode 1 as a whole feels more weighted
towards action set-pieces
and although their interactions are
still a series of QuickTime events
there's more involvement in the
moment-to-moment scuffles now after
delivering a flurry of bone-crunching
hooks and uppercuts you can choose
whether you want to follow up with a
roundhouse or a body slam or you'll have
to tap buttons multiple times to ensure
your batarangs hit all the goons in the
area it's a small change but one that
encourages players to stay focused and
engaged as with all telltale games the
way you respond to characters through
dialogue choices not only defines how
the story branches but now also
redefines relationships it can be
difficult to see someone you once
considered a friend now doubting you
through no fault of your own
this shake-up injects further drama into
existing dynamics which means you can
never truly feel at ease during a
conversation while the episode is less
overt than season 1 about trying to
deconstruct Batman and Bruce Wayne the
Riddler is used to assess the principles
they operate under each new saw like
deathtrap questions what sacrifices the
Caped Crusader is willing to make in
pursuit of his justice it's subtle but
telltale is picking at the line between
hero and criminal in a way that could
unravel Batman's sense of self with
interesting implications the Riddler's
arrival has also attracted the attention
of the agency this alpha is headed up by
Amanda Waller and DC fans will
immediately appreciate the implications
her introduction has Waller is known to
be one of the most powerful non
superhuman characters in the DC Universe
regularly scheming and politicking to
keep the worst criminals and greatest
heroes under her thumb she begins to
undermine the relationship between
Commissioner Gordon and Batman by
creating a rift between them something
which the player must then work to mend
she becomes yet another plate for
players to spin a new source of stress
in the game
decision-making moments of course
there's also the matter of John Doe who
abruptly reappears having been released
from Arkham Asylum with a full clean
bill of health however he still ever so
slightly unhinged but at the same time
unusually helpful to Batman's
investigations which once again
emphasizes the actions have consequences
mantra that Telltale's games are built
on
do you accept help from someone who deep
down you know will eventually turn on
you gosh John I don't know my schedule
just so packed these days please don't
blow me off without the need to retell
the origin story and unburdened by that
baggage season 2 of tell towns Batman
series has started strongly with a
variety of well realized new characters
there are a number of tough
decision-making moments that will give
players pause and invite them to
consider the impact their choices could
have while gameplay is not markedly
different combat is tweaked just enough
to make it an improvement over its
previous iteration overall the Enigma is
a successful opening chapter to a Batman
story that's shaping up to be more
ambitious than anything telltale
attempted in the first season
[Music]